[Musique]
qui d'entre eux voient le permis ok donc
c'est très bien parce que le permis ça
vous permet de conduire un véhicule et
d'aller d'un point a à un point b
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec moi
donc tout le monde pour conduire un
véhicule
il faut passer un permis on est d'accord
tout le monde est d'accord ou pas
d'accord très bien donc mon travail à
moi aujourd'hui c'est de vous apprendre
à conduire un véhicule peut être le
véhicule le plus puissant de l'humanité
le cerveau le cerveau j'irai même le
mental mon objectif aujourd'hui c'est
vraiment vous parler du mental
tout ce que nous avons vécu vous et moi
jusqu'ici nous ramène à cet instant
précis vous allez tous repartir d'ici
avec un plan d'action que vous allez
pouvoir utiliser tout de suite et
obtenir des résultats
donc notre vie n'est qu'un clin d'oeil à
l'échelle de l'éternité
mais nos actions existent pour une durée
indéterminée
en 1999 j'ai obtenu mon bébé
comptabilisés avec mention laissez nous
tranquilles donc du coup j'ai été
propulsé sur le marché du travail et
sans diplôme sans vraiment de
compétences entrepreneuriales et rien du
tout j'ai commencé à chercher un job
j'ai été recruté par les galeries
lafayette ou pas si vous connaissez donc
l'un des plus grands magasins au monde
et j'y ai fait deux mois donc c'est mon
premier job
à l'issue de ce job mon responsable me
prend dans une salle et n'diaye coutts
et bien pas bien bossé alors tandis qu à
toi c'est ton premier job est ce que ça
t'a plu je veux dire moi c'est bon je
peux rester ici jusqu'à la retraite
et là il explose de rire et nissim said
la retraite que dans quarante ans que tu
me parles de retraite je dis voilà j'ai
pas diplôme j'ai un bep comptabilité
sait pas vraiment ce que ce que je veux
faire la comptabilité
donc c'est moi je suis bien essayé plus
grand magasin du monde j'aime ce que je
fais je parte pas de carton donc ça va
ça me plaît
et là il dit là en fait faillite c'est
pas du tout comme ça il ya tant à
potentiel tu vas aller plus loin que ça
et c'est aujourd'hui de lila grâce à
alassane ouattara
j'ai créé une entreprise qui consiste à
aider les gens à se lancer sur internet
à monétiser leurs compétences ou les
entreprises à développer leur chiffre
d'affaires grâce au web marketing et à
toutes les
compétences entrepreneuriales en
parallèle on a lancé un mouvement qui
s'appelle coincé riddle l'objectif de ce
mouvement c'est que chacun puisse
utiliser ses compétences son pouvoir
sans dont son talent pour impacter le
monde sur plusieurs générations
alors concrètement qu'est ce que ça veut
dire impact elle monte sur plusieurs
générations
le simple fait de faire un travail sur
soi et de développer d'obtenir des
résultats moins d'impact automne est
automatiquement les gens autour de nous
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ça où
est ce que je suis le seul à avoir
atteint ses objectifs là absolument pas
j'ai alain de lille a rencontré un
certain nombre de personnes qui ont eu
le même parcours et pourtant en fait on
n'a absolument pas les mêmes
caractéristiques donc personnalités
différents profils de personnalités
différentes compétences différentes
mais résultat exponentielle c'est une
personne que j'ai rencontrée il ya deux
ans au niger donc sur la droite
je les rencontrais dans un village du
sahel on était parti faire une
distribution de denrées alimentaires
juste avant le ramadan il faisait très
chaud et c'est vais pas ramené grand
chose on avait ramené un sac de riz et
quelques condiments supplémentaire pour
passer le ramadan c'est pas énorme et il
le dit écoute moi j'ai grandi dans ce
village et je peux t'assurer une chose
je n'ai jamais vu une aide humanitaire
aussi incroyable que celle là à sac de
riz et quelques condiments je n'ai
jamais vu ça et même si vous ne revenez
pas l'année prochaine
votre nom restera à jamais gravé dans
notre coeur et voilà il n'ya pas plus
fort que cette phrase là est justement
en fait toi concrètement tu rouge en 4/4
aujourd'hui tu ford puis d'un
entrepreneur tu as grandi dans ce
village là dans le désert au plein
milieu du désert
inzaghi j'ai grandi dans le désert et
aujourd'hui j'ai la chance de pouvoir
faire un métier que j'aime je ford et
puis environ 50 voire 100 par mois c'est
l'une des entreprises du niger qui
forment le plus depuis extraordinaire ou
non est ce que vous voulez savoir
comment il a fait je vous lis dans un
instant donc hier j'étais intelligent je
voulais changer le monde
aujourd'hui je suis sage et je me change
moi même donc cette citation aller
absolument dans la réalité en tout cas
moi je vois vraiment les choses comme ça
si on veut changer le monde si on veut
impacté le monde si on veut impacté les
gens autour de soi
eh bien il faut déjà faire un travail
sur soi
est-ce que vous reconnaissez ça ok donc
fonte des glaces marée noire toutes les
problématiques liées au niveau de
l'environnement aujourd'hui
eh bien je crois que c'est le désastre
environnemental le plus je crois que
c'est un objectif en fait pour chacun un
objectif pour chacun et c'est le
challenge du siècle mais il ya un autre
challenge dont on parle pas et qui
pourtant tout aussi important et c'est
un désastre également est-ce que vous
reconnaissez ok donc j'ai lu une étude
récemment je vais vous en reparler juste
dans un enfin je vais revenir juste dans
un instant j'ai lu une étude récemment
qui disait que dans cent ans les déchets
spatiaux aller en uvre et l'humanité les
déchets spatiaux risque d'emmurer
l'humanité si on ne fait rien donc
l'homme se crée sa propre prison si vous
voulez en fait je nomme il a déjà créé
sa propre prison le simple fait de ne
pas utiliser son potentiel neurologiques
mentales telles qu'elles se doit il
s'est emmuré en réalité dans une prison
donc je ne peux pas ce n'est pas
possible il ya un certain nombre d'
excuse qui suivent
en même temps le cerveau c'est quelque
chose d'extrêmement puissant c'est
extrêmement puissant c'est qu'elle sait
alors sans rentrer dans des éléments
très technique le cerveau aujourd'hui
permet de tourner morizet tout ce que
vous faites devient une habitude
tout ce que vous faites devient une
habitude tout ce que vous tout ce à quoi
vous pensez de ce que vous ressentez si
vous le répéter automatiquement le
cerveau prend la main alors le cerveau
il est un grand protecteur également si
vous marchez près d'une falaise ou d'un
tapis qui peut vous faire tomber et bien
automatiquement il veut dire attention
attention là tu risques de tomber si ça
ne suffit pas il vous envoie une image
une image qui justifie qu une référence
dans votre cerveau qui vous rappellent à
quel point c'est dangereux si ça ne
suffit pas eh bien il vous envoie ce que
l'on appelle la peur est là ça vous fait
réagir bon c'est une émotion qui vous
fait réagir et qu'est ce que vous faites
généralement bien vous rebrousser chemin
parce que ça peut être dangereux
le problème c'est que à un moment donné
quand on n'utilise pas du tout ses
facultés mentales
et bien tout commence à ressembler à une
falaise projet de vie projet
professionnel projet entrepreneurial
d'évolution tout simplement à partir du
moment où on cherche à évoluer si on n'a
pas fait travailler son cerveau
comme il connaît pas ils sont à attendre
dans l'inconnu c'est une falaise donc si
tu commence à marcher au bord tu vas
tomber et on a peur et ont rebroussé
chemin et la finalité en fait de ça
c'est que on a un outil extrêmement
puissant mais qu'on utilise pas on
laisse à l'abandon
et c'est aussi un rat un protecteur
comme je vous l'aï dit et alors le
cerveau et les puissants et il est
bienveillant il est tellement puissant
qu'il est capable de générer 35 mille
excuses à la seconde
je ne peux pas et en plus il est
bienveillant quand vous y arrivez à vous
dis ok t'inquiète pas ce n'est pas de ta
faute c'est la faute des autres
c'est la faute du temps c'est la faute
de la famille c'est la faute de ton
entourage
donc en fait il est il est tellement
puissant en fait le cerveau quand on l'a
pas utilisé qu'à un moment donné même
des citations super aspirante celle de
jim rhodes que tout le monde connaît
vous êtes la moyenne des cinq personnes
autour de vous c'est quelque chose
d'inspirant pas ce que ça veut dire que
finalement c'est important l'entourage
c'est important de bien s'entourer
si on a des objectifs à atteindre et
bien l'un des moyens les plus simples et
bien c'est de bien s'entourer et nous
souvent en fait quand j'ai changé avec
des des clients des membres de mes
formations les utilisent cette même
citation qui est inspirante
mais pour dire voilà en fait moi je suis
là moyen des cinq personnes je suis là
il ya cinq personnes c'est mort je ne
peux pas faire plus que ce que je fais
là donc c'est une excuse en fait mon
époux ne me soutient pas changeons des
poux donc on va essayer de pousser
vraiment la logique où ma famille ne me
comprends pas change de famille ma ville
ce pays ne m'inspire pas change de pays
il ya plus d'espoir dans ce monde
finalement quand on voit tous les
cataclysmes tous les problèmes au niveau
de l'environnement etc
il n'y a plus d'espoir finalement et
bien change de planète mais le truc
c'est que si tu veux changer de palettes
change vite de planète parce que bientôt
l'humanité sera en muret
donc en fait on l'a compris on est
obligé de composer avec nous même si
vous voulez atteindre des objectifs
ambitieux quels qu'ils soient est bien
le meilleur moyen c'est de commencer par
vous tout simplement en moyenne une
méthode que j'apprécie particulièrement
qui s'appelle l'impact marketing ce sont
des stratégies donc un ensemble de
stratégies une boîte à outils de
stratégies qui permettent donc de ce
programme et l'euro logiquement ou sur
le plan du comportement d'accord est-ce
que vous pensez que c'est possible déjà
oui oui j'ai trois oublis dans la salle
il ya peu d'espoir on a déjà au mur et
l'humanité ok donc en fait il ya une
méthode
franchement il ya plein de méthodes
plein de stratégie est quelque chose
dont je parle a fait régulièrement sais
je sais pas si vous connaissez le
système d'activation réticulaire lever
la main si vous connaissez ok c'est un
puissant une puissante options de votre
cerveau récemment je voulais acheter une
voiture
je voulais acheter une voiture ça me
tenait à coeur c'était important pour
moi à partir du moment que j'ai commencé
à mettre le nez dedans je voyais la même
voiture partout en fait cette voiture à
la toujours été là c'est juste qu'on
n'était pas programmé pour la voir et le
système d'activation réticulaire et bien
c'est un outil du cerveau une fonction
qui va vous aider à identifier certaines
choses et ça on peut le programme et moi
je l'appelle le gps mental en gros si on
a un objectif à atteindre je sais pas je
veux créer une entreprise et que je
commence à alimenter mon esprit de
nouvelles informations liées à la
création d'entreprise que voilà ça me
tient à coeur donc je ressors des
émotions va le cerveau fini par
comprendre que c'est important pour moi
et comme il sait que c'est important
pour moi eh bien il va parvenir à
identifier tous les éléments pour les
raccourcis toutes les discussions toutes
les personnes qui me rapproche de cet
objectif là c'est pas un outil génial ça
le système d'activation réticulaire
c'est un outil extraordinaire à lui seul
en fait à lui seul il peut vous aider à
cheminer de manière accélérée vers
l'atteinte de vos objectifs
aujourd'hui je voulais vous parler de
cette méthode être on part de soi donc
la méthode s'appelle être
c'est une méthode en quatre points
premièrement expérimenté très souvent en
fait le l'objection qui revient le plus
est je ne sais pas par où commencer
trois ans plus tard tu reviens il sait
toujours pas par où commencer
en fait le meilleur moyen de 2
de commencer et bien c'est d'alimenter
son cerveau de nouvelles informations
demain staff un aliment ton estomac de
nourriture ça on sait tous le faire si
tu ne sais pas où aller alimentons
cerveau de nouvelles informations parce
que tu as tout veut tout simplement dire
que ton cerveau ne contient pas les
informations dont il a besoin pour
avancer
est ce que ça vous paraît clair ok
ça c'est un schéma qu'on connaît bien
mais qu'on ne connaît pas chaque pensée
que nous avons dans la journée ou un
ensemble de pensée entre elles une
émotion des émotions qui vont dans le
même sens que les pensées les émotions
entraîne des actions donc j'ai peur je
recule je suis une action j'ai un
comportement et ses actions et bien
entraîne une expérience où vit une
expérience particulière et tout ça est
lié
si je n'alimente pas mon cerveau de
nouvelles informations qu est ce qui va
se passer et bien concrètement je vais
avoir les mêmes pensées les mêmes
émotions les mêmes actions les mêmes
expériences pas d'évolution en fait dont
il ya un doute chez grasset d'alimenter
son cerveau de nouvelles informations de
vivre de nouvelles expériences
ça va venir alimenter son cerveau de
nouvelles informations et donc forcément
de nouvelles émotions ses émotions va
entraîner de nouvelles actions nouveaux
comportements et ces nouveaux
comportements et bien vont susciter de
nouvelles expériences enrichissantes et
ses expériences enrichissantes et bien
vont alimenter de nouvelles pensées et
là on est en fait dans un cercle
vertueux on évolue sur le plan
neurologique alors expérimenté donc
c'est la clé expérimenté je n'ai pas
d'idée je sais pas par où commencer
j'expérimente ensuite transmettez
transmettez c'est une astuce est quelque
chose que j'apprends de nouveau c'est
intéressant ça peut aider les miens
eh bien je vais tout simplement
transmettre l'information immédiatement
en transmettant l'information qu'est ce
que je fais et bien ged la personne
autour de moi et en même temps et bien
moi ça me permet de consolider ces
informations là alors il ya le conseil a
le subconscient si je vous dis
choisissez un travail que vous aimez
jamais vous n'aurez l'impression de
travailler
ouais c'est génial vous allez sortir
vous avez oublié pourquoi parce que vous
avez conscientiser sa saison avec
conscience oui c'est vrai il a raison
mais demain on fait tous vos
automatismes vont revenir
d'accord donc l'idée en fait c'est faire
passer les informations directement dans
l'inconscient l'inconscient c'est lui
qui gère tout en fait il lui qui gère
les automatismes donc du coup l'un des
moyens pour ce faire c'est la répétition
mental ou physique où les expériences
émotionnelles correctrices les
expériences de façon générale ensuite le
troisième point est bien c'est
rechercher regarder recadrer donc en
fait on est on est unique on est une
recette unique composé d'ingrédients un
certain nombre d'ingrédients qui nous
rendent unique on a des qualités on a
des défauts est ce qu'on prend le temps
vraiment d'analyser ses qualités ses
défauts
rarement
et bien dans nos qualités nos défauts il
ya un pouvoir il ya une kryptonite c'est
un peu comme superman situé identifie
ton pouvoir
eh bien tu peut capitaliser dessus en
fait tu peux savoir en fait comment
utiliser plus de ce pouvoir là pour
atteindre des objectifs ambitieux pareil
pour le défaut la faiblesse si j'arrive
à identifier la kryptonite ce qu'il fait
gâcher tous mes projets bien je m'en
éloigne en fait j'essaye de muscler en
fait la partie neurologique qui me
permet de surmonter cette faiblesse donc
ici en fait lorsque je vous invite à
faire en rentrant chez vous aujourd'hui
et honnêtement c'est la clé la clé de
beaucoup de choses parce que tout est
déjà là en fait avoir cependant internet
vous à créer
il vous accueille avec un pouvoir que
vous n'utilisez pas parce que vous
n'avez pas conscience souvent fait pour
le fait de manière complètement inné et
on ne sait pas que ça a un pouvoir
analyser vos réussites et vos échecs
vous allez retrouver ce schéma réussit
échec
vous avez trouvé que la réussite et bien
c'est une c'est la conséquence de penser
d'émotion et d'action spécifique et ça
donne lieu à une expérience je continue
très rapidement alors que fuyez vous le
plus lisez bien donc l'imperfection la
solitude
l'échec la banalité l'envahissement la
trahison
l'immobilisme la faiblesse le conflit
vous fuyez une de ces choses et dont
vous prenez des décisions pour fuir une
de ces choses ça ça détermine votre cv
votre faiblesse donc très général
généralement il ya neuf profil de
personnalité qui ressemble à ça il ya
donc un pouvoir
donc si c'est la perfection que vous
fuyez le plus eh bien ce sera la
capacité à entendre à la perfection et
ça c'est une capacité en fait ça va
pouvoir que vous pouvez utiliser et
capitaliser dessus pour atteindre des
objectifs
je vais essayer d'aller un peu plus vite
j'ai bientôt terminé et eux entourés
vous alors on a vu tout à l'heure qui on
peut s'en sortir aux 600 l'entourage
même si personne autour de vous écoutez
bien j'ai fini sur sa même si personne
autour de vous ne peut vous aider
l'entourage d'eva bien et bien
souvenez-vous simplement qu' il y à un
créateur qui est un créateur et quand
vous lui demandez quelque chose vous
savez spécifiquement ce que vous voulez
parce que vous avez alimenter votre
cerveau de nouvelles informations
et bien vous allez faire une demande
spécifique ensuite vous allez demander
avec la conviction qu'il peut vous
exaucé donc j'ai la conviction ok moi je
veux ça ça
je sais que tu peux mais je sais et je
vais faire le bien avec ça et enfin on
se lève de sa prière ou de son
invocation en ayant la conviction que ça
y est je suis déjà exaucé parce que le
fait de demander
déjà on reçoit rolls et j'ai pas besoin
de vous présenter les textes donc
demandé avec conviction avec de la
gratitude et au moment où on demande
on essaie de se visualiser en train
d'atteindre l'objectif quand on fait ça
qu'est ce qu'on fait eh bien on est en
train de créer progressivement ce que
l'on appelle des souvenirs du futur on
sait que les souvenirs aujourd'hui quand
vous blessez quelque part eh bien ça
vous marque à vie
dès que vous voyez l'élément qui vous a
blessé mais on a peur on s'y attend
attention donc du coup en fait le fait
d'avoir de la gratitude et de visualiser
en train d'attendre son objectif cinq
fois par jour
eh bien ça nous permet de créer des
souvenirs de futur qui nous aide à avoir
de plus en plus confiance dans
l'atteinte de notre objectif
ok donc vous allez commencer c'est
terminé d'accord c'est terminé vous
allez commencer petit parce que ça fait
peur les objectifs d'ambition commencer
petit ça va grandir et ensuite vous
allez atteindre un point de non retour à
ce moment-là vous deviendrez inarrêtable
je prends juste l'exemple que je vous ai
dit au début donc cette personne était
un apprenti en fait il vivait dans le
village il a vu arriver des ong
il leur a dit voilà en fait qu'est-ce
que vous comment vous fabriquer les
puits ou lui a expliqué dit s'il vous
plaît je veux travailler gratuitement
pour vous juste en émoi on l'a emmené il
a travaillé pendant cinq ans avec tués
et il a fini par créer son entreprise
est relayée justement la loi angie en
question donc apprentis experts
entrepreneurs une dernière chose a joui
à chacun d'entre vous le meilleur outil
en réalité pour réussir ses concerts
idem